herzlichen dank für die so überaus
freundliche begrüßung
also ich glaube dass friedrich merz ein
interesse daran hat dass es am freitag
zu einem großen schaulaufen kommen
zwischen annegret kramp karrenbauer und
ihm selbst
wie bei allem was was friedrich merz in
letzter zeit aber gemacht habe ist ist
da auch schon die luft ein bisschen raus
das land vor der partei und immer die
partei vor jedem einzelnen von uns und
daran wird sich jeder halten auch ein
vorsitzender friedrich merz also alles
in allem ist ziemlich viel wirbel
angefangen worden nach der thüringer
aber es wird vielleicht als sturm im
wasserglas frau kam kam frau war von
anfang an einer schwierigen situation
das haben wir auch alle zugegeben und
das wird auch jetzt immer wieder erwähnt
durch die trennung von kanzleramt und
parteivorsitz
das führt immer wieder zur konstellation
dass für schlechte leistungen die
parteivorsitzende verantwortlich gemacht
wird und für gute leistungen die
kanzlerin die toiletten für das dritte
geschlecht einführen
das ist für die männer die noch nicht
wissen ob sie noch stehen dürfen beim
pinkeln oder schon sitzen müssen dafür
dass diese toilette sie hat in letzter
zeit bei vielen gelegenheiten vielleicht
ein etwas ungeschicktes verhalten einen
tag gelegt ich würde sagen es sind
meistens kommunikative fehler gewesen
und man kann aber meiner ansicht nach
auch beobachten dass diese fehler größer
gemacht wurden als sie tatsächlich sind
mein vorschlag ist dass wir eine
international kontrollierte
sicherheitszone einrichten unter
einbeziehung der türkei und unter
einbeziehung von russland ich erkläre
mir das damit dass in der partei die
stimmung ein bisschen gekippt ist
zugunsten frau von der
parteivorsitzenden und das hört man auch
einen halben das in
hintergrundgesprächen sich einfach ganz
offen runter geputzt wird das kann so
nicht weitergehen und ich kann
ihr schlicht nicht vorstellen dass diese
art des regierens in deutschland noch
zwei jahre dauert bis zum ende dieser
wahlperiode bis ende 20 21 richters
hatte er nach der thüringen war die
regierung und auch frau merkel frontal
angegriffen
das war etwas überspannt diese kritik
also er hat ja gesagt die arbeit der
oder das erscheinungsbild der großen
koalition sein konnten schlecht annegret
kramp karrenbauer ist nicht die einzige
die hier im mittelpunkt der kritik zu
stehen hat sondern es gibt auch andere
und das gesamte erscheinungsbild der
deutschen bundesregierung ist einfach
grottenschlecht und daran muss sich
etwas ändern
er trägt da ein bisschen dick auf habe
ich den eindruck
warum er das macht ich glaube einfach
deswegen weil das die einzige
möglichkeit für ihn ist irgendein echo
hervor zu rufen weil er nicht in den
parteigremien drin sitzt war wurden
entsprechend mehrheiten suchen könnte
und sich durch durchsetzen könnte der
der versuch die direktwahl durchzusetzen
ist ist eindeutig ein zeichen dafür dass
er sich sozusagen bei der basis zu hause
fühlt das wäre ein weg
muss vielleicht noch zu ändern
[Applaus]
er ist sehr gut er kann
da kann ein saal zum toben gruppe gehen
so liebe freunde
danach sehnen sich viele nach nach 14
jahren angela merkel jedoch ein sehr
rationalen kühlen nüchternen
regierungsstil gepflegt hat und die
leute auch nicht unbedingt mitreißen
kann
für ihn ist das relativ einfach weil er
von außen kommt er ist sozusagen nicht
befleckt durch die ganzen kompromisse
und durch die regierungsarbeit der
letzten jahre und kann deswegen in
vielerlei hinsicht klare kante zeigen
auf einen punkt ohne klare positionen
bekommen wir keine bessere
wahlergebnisse liebe vor dem
kunstfreunde also übertrieben gedacht
allergie wie emotional an das an die
zukunft denken
die finden eher weiblich märz
[Applaus]
also ich glaube ich dass das bild märz
die einfach gemacht hat in der partei
und ich zum kanzlerkandidaten
durchzusetzen
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat weil sie
die parteivorsitzende ist erstmal das
erste zugriffsrecht
ich glaube dass da dabei wird es auch
bleiben ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
dann armin laschet noch dazu kommt als
als möglicher kandidat der zurzeit
glaube ich in den gremien ziemlich
starke position hat weil er das sind
noch nicht fallen ganz gut macht die
regierung weil er auch einen klaren kurs
hat in vielerlei hinsicht
der vierte im bunde ist aber immer noch
jetzt sparen stehe ich glaube dass man
den nicht vergessen darf und jens spahn
ist jemand der eine ganz gute
regierungsarbeit leistet und der immer
noch ja so der jugendliche
hoffnungsträger in der cdu ist also ich
würde die rechnung nicht ohne jens spahn
machen
der star ist die cdu es geht nicht darum
wer jeder einzelne in der cdu
es geht darum dass unsere partei glänzt
dafür müssen wir arbeiten dafür müsst
ihr mittun dafür bitte ich euch um euer
vertrauen
[Applaus]